you know New Orleans when I was growing
up the the a lot of the artists over
there were like the big timers and uh
you know little whitewash that hip-hop
revolution the New Orleans episode uh uh
I need a great this whole I'm gonna
agree watch this whole episode and write
down all the things I don't want anyone
starts with like Master P and M in New
Orleans for me bro it's the first black
thing Memphis it has the longest
cultural significance in hip-hop right
people can argue me but like when you
think about what music sounds like now
hip-hop it all comes back to this
Memphis sound like this aggressive this
dark and the trap beats and like it's
just lasted forever and it was a small
flash tin pan with three six and like
8ball & MJG were doing it and the New
Orleans was like the same kind of sound
and it's an electronic drum sound they
like blood the electro they loved like
many freshers and they can you know like
these kind of like 808 sounds and they
mix it with the second lion jazz and
then Big Tymers and then Master P came
up with the idea of independent label
and you [ __ ] crushing and it's cash
money came out and then and had this
amazing bounce to music which I love
someone that's why I was gonna get to it
about scene because uh yeah like Big
Freedia like some of the Artemis she's
the most popular but the bounce scene
there has been probably the biggest
thing it's come out and it's never
laughs and it's the same Rhino Freda uh
I was I worked with this um I worked a
couple bounce artists there's flyboy ki
know there's Cissy know be it's it's
very gay it's crazy that's how gay the
hip-hop scene in New Orleans is a lot of
the rappers and labels you know you talk
to like mr. cool or like these guys I
was with I was a mystic on the studio
know and after got a jail and I had just
on this record called express yourself
with um Nicki to be who was another gay
bounce artist from New Orleans and um
it's like my fusion of like dance music
in New Orleans bounce back then and I'm
never playing it from mystical in the
studio I was like man can you jump on
this super game the video was gay too
and I was like can you jump on this
record and he no mystical said to me was
like bro that's hard that's actually New
Orleans music and he knew that's like
that's acts at the scene he wasn't like
homophobic or anybody's like man I just
can't come out of jail and do it like
this record right now I can't really
like do a verse on a gay bowser Eckerd
but um yeah I'll be right but but at the
same time he had respect and like knew
that
like real New Orleans music cuz if you
don't realize like even the you know big
Fritos in that record with Drake that
came out last year I didn't know that
because Drake's last album had a lot of
bounce influences on New Orleans records
on it but there's not there hasn't been
a that there hasn't been a strong hip
hop's been the only our bounces been the
only real music to come out of that area
kind of I feel like there's that one
interesting nineties oh you mean not
third a third eye but three goes down
something like that Reaser studio when i
worked on music with them oh I need you
talking about they're nice guys - yeah
that's one other thing I knew was really
I remember run through the way there's
nothing just a jam man from New Orleans
- but I forget oh dude one of them owns
a freaking restaurant where I'll take my
stepdad all the time and I mean if you
get if you want to learn for me meters
is bunk and country completely mastered
majesty their funk but they're like
country bro and their instrumental like
meters are like wife they're like one of
my biggest influences of all time like
they're so dope like a New Orleans funk
is just like we're gonna learn about
music New Orleans is the birth of all
American music in my opinion Wow like
everything comes from New Orleans mhm
you know from the history of like it's
the perfect combination of African music
and European music you look at indie
band New Orleans maybe an indie band
indie rock New Orleans but there hasn't
been a reason why there hasn't been a
strong hip-hop artists that's come out
of there in a while I mean you think
there would be so well there's like
others in the NBA young boy from Baton
Rouge his last name was that sure he's
might be the biggest oh there's also
there's Kevin gates yeah maybe I'm boys
from that is he from Baton Rouge I mean
he's like one of the biggest like
low-key yeah he like low keys weren't
the biggest figures in hip-hop and I
don't even know one name a young boy
song but like he just every girl knows
him it was music he just he
all we love him and busi but he blue he
lives in atlanta busi is that guy just
came out of jail like he was like he
missed all technology and then just came
what is it so great he and he denied it
I asked him weak as he came and I asked
him I said do you think that because you
were in jail you missed kind of like the
evolution of Technology so you came into
Instagram were just way too real I was
so real I mean it didn't register for
him but I thought that's exactly that he
got out and is like friends gave us
iPhone is like what is this like he was
like like literally came out of jail
like went for it was he missed the the
clutch parts of technology yep and just
came back like insane like he's a legend
now anybody you come back to him a lot
of people like if you do like that dirty
hip-hop he he's the guy and that's I
don't know that much about Baton Rouge I
know I only went there once to actually
went to little Bootsy I did a uh I was
in Baton Rouge for like my birthday I
had nothing going I was in New Orleans
for my birthday when I like turned like
24 I just went by myself to like read
and just I loved Louisiana just like go
to bars and stuff and I had a friend
there and we went to see boost he did a
concert at a mall in Baton Rouge and I
went saw was before he went to jail and
that's all the time we were in Baton
Rouge was go see boo see Adam awesome
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one